こんにちはえ大臣のですよろしくお願いし
ます私はあの心理学という領域でえ仕事を
しております特にあの学校心理学という
ところでえ子供とか学校を支援する仕事を
しておりますあの心理学という皆さん
色んなイメージがあると思うんですけども
ま大きくはて2つの側面がありまして1つ
はま人間のえ心とかこを色んなデータを
使って調べて研究するという速でもう1つ
はえ心理学に基づいて色々悩んだりえ苦戦
してる人を支援するという実践的な作特に
あの実践的なことを私カリングとかやっ
てるわけですけどもこう人と人との繋がり
の中でやってるわけでこう人との繋が
りっていうのはすごく関心をえ持ってます
今日はそのとこの話をしたいと思います
それからえもう1つは私あのえ30歳大大
部分あのアメリカで過ごしてえ40で日本
に書いてきた帰国おじさんですね帰国市場
なんて言えない帰国おじさんなんですけど
もあのアメリカにいる間にま色んな方とえ
関わったり繋がることができていろんな
人種の方とかあの私はクリスチャンじゃ
ないんですけどいろんな教会にも生かして
いただいてえ色んなことを感じることが
できましたそれで日本に帰ってきて
しばらくゴスタしてたんですけどもま
2011年のえ3月11日のえ東の大震災
があった時に本当に多くの方から大丈夫
かっていうこうメールをいただいてえ
Facebook見たけどあなた持って
ないと私Facebookやって
ないメールを知ってる人だけねメール来た
んですけどそれからあの私学校審理士って
いう日本のえ団体の代表してるもんです
からあの東日本のね色々な子供た支援魅力
ながら仲間としてるわけですけどもその時
の資料作りとかアイデアとか本当にあの
色んな国の方からサポートされていてあ
またえこの人たち繋がったなっていうこと
でとても嬉しく感じていますまそんなとこ
で今日お話たんで最初がですねオンリーえ
ナンバーワオンリー1とこういきなり
スマップの歌のようなものが出てきました
けどもまみんな違ってみんないい私大好き
な言葉ですでも最近あの心配なのはですね
え特に子供たちを見てるとなんかオンリー
ワンになろうとすごく頑張ってるような気
がしてそれが心配で前の空気を読んでえ
キャラを被らないようにというすいません
覚えたばっかりのけついてる分からないん
ですけど同じようなキャラクターがいると
ちょっと避けて遠慮してしまうこれ
ちょっと気についたなと思ってます頑張ら
なくてもオワじゃないですか同じ人いない
んだからオワなんですよむしろオンリー
ワンだけどもオンリーワン同士てどうやっ
て繋がっていくといいんだろうねみたいな
のをも練習するのがいいのかなと思って
ますですから同じも違うも大切なんですよ
ねそこで私が今日皆さんにお伝えしたいの
が人とつがるえオンリーワということです
これはまだスマップを歌ってはありますね
はいえ茨城県に夕にこという学校があり
ましてここの学校はえ私と相談して
キャッチフレーズ使っていただきますので
えまあ嬉しく思うんですけどもどうやっ
たら自分らしく繋がる力を持てるかどう
やったらまハウですねどうやったら人と
繋がるかということで今日少しえお話をし
たいと思いますで今日題材として
取り上げるのが男は辛いよという映画の
風船のえ
ラこの中で男は辛いよご覧になったことは
なるから
手ありがとうございます今日は平均が若い
ので少し説明が必要だなということが理解
できましたはいえもう1人がですねつわ西
というビッコミックオリジナルていう私の
愛読書があるんですけどもえそこでずっと
シリーズでやっていてえ映画にも入りまし
たえ釣り場西見たことのあるのあこちらの
が勢がありますねえはいえ3つ目がですね
あのテレビ野菜で今ずっと連載している
ドラマの相棒というのを取り上げたいと
思いますそこで杉下京さん
ますけど相棒見たことあるか手この圧倒的
ですねはいえウさんうございますそれでは
あのはい次に行きたいと思いますがまず
あのトラさんから行きたいと思うんです
けどもはい教えたか
なはいえ男は辛いよトラさんですえご存知
ないかおます男は辛いよていうのはですね
え車トラジいわゆるトラさんが全国を回っ
ていくなぜならば虎さんの職業は敵や露天
シだいろんなとこでお店を出すクさんにき
ましたでお店を出して物を売っていくその
時にその地域地域に入っていって地域で
色々苦戦してるとであるんですねえ配布症
をなくしたとか仕事でうまくいかないって
いう人と出会ってえトラさんがサポートし
てまサポートする理由はサポートの対象が
まどなで素敵だからていう理由が8割5ぐ
閉めてでさんが関わり繋がっていく中でえ
その方がこうまた元気を取り戻していくと
いうとこですこのえスライドはですね黒
さんが東北の方を1秒か2秒ぐらいの
ちっちゃな電車で旅してた時に電車が
キキキキっと止まりましてそうすると電車
の下にえ中年のサービマの方がよく伝わっ
ていてま自殺を試みてましだけどあの幸い
あの怪我をしなでトさんほっけないのでえ
俺が忙しいのにて言いなら本当は暇なん
ですけどえ旅館で泊一緒にしてえその方も
元気になって次の日の朝というところがえ
これになりますでトラさんの繋がり方って
いうのは100人に対してえ100の顔で
繋がるんですねでそさんはですね非日常
ですよ旅人ですからで人が木の時に繋がっ
てくれる
ばよそ者なんですとさんの繋がり方こと見
ましたいうことましたねすいません戻り
ますえもか
な空さんの繋がり方は3通りあります今日
あのどのように繋がるかっていう説明が
え人との人にあの共感するていうことと
味方になるということとそれから自分を
出すという3通りで3人のこと説明します
けれども相手の世界に共感するということ
です相手がどんな気持ちなのかな例えばえ
子供が苦戦ししている人の親さんと私は
カスがて面談することがありますけどその
気持ちになる大変ですねていう気持ちにな
るっていうのは大変だなと分かることじゃ
なくてこちらも辛くなるんですね共感し
ますのでそれが相手のえ世界に共感する
あるいは相手の文化に染まるということ
ですよねはい2つ目が相手の世話すプロ
さんは相手の願いを叶えるように頑張り
ますえ例えばですねあの
色々な子供の発達のことで苦戦してる親子
さんと私が面談をしてる時にはその方が
そのお子さんが利用できるようなパソコン
教師とかというのも私も一緒に探したりし
ますよねこういうサポートもあります3つ
目が相手に自分の意見を言うということ
ですけど虎さじに言うとですね偉そうな
ことを言うよりもなんか自分の失敗感を
話すとえなんかお互いがほっとするという
ことがありますね皆さん失敗だお持ち
でしょうかありますますよねえ出し惜しみ
しない人と関わる時には喋るといいと思う
んですけどもそれでえお互いの繋がりがえ
進むことがあります私もあの自分の子供に
よく失敗談を話しますと次の日近所のこと
みんな知っていたよくあるんですけどはい
え次がですね釣り箱市の浜ですね中高市
っていうのはス建生っていうあの大きな
会社に浜ちゃん務めているんですけどもえ
そこで彼はですねえ業績はABCのCです
ねえキングイオCですね強調性Aの丸です
ねこ大事なんですよねえ社長のスーさんと
仲良しで色々えドタバタ兵の中で周りを
元気にしていくですねでこれは朝え長い
こと追っかけていたあの魚が釣れたって
いう朝の姿ですけども彼はこの後戻ってき
てええ服を着替えて会社に行くんだと思っ
たらこれ最初の釣り箱の第1シンなんです
けどこのえ釣のジャケットを抜いたらしり
ワシャットね使て便利ですよね神の人生は
着替えないんです一1が続いていくんです
朝ずり趣味も昼の仕事もえそれから夜家族
とのえ段々も人生の一です働くために遊ぶ
遊ぶために働くのではなくてどれも大事
クライフバランスのやばパイオニアみたい
なもんですねはいなぜハマちゃんがこんな
マイペースで自分買ってあのトラさんは
100人に対して100の顔がという人な
んですけどもえハマちゃんは100人に
対していつも自分の顔でマベース行ってる
んですよこいう繋がり方もあるんですよだ
けどあの相手とうまくいくっていうのは
適度な距離感あんですねえ同僚のえ方の家
に行った時にずっと長く引きこもってるお
さんがいて一緒に釣りに行く場面なんです
けども
えこちら側がはちゃんでこちら側が弟さん
ですけどもはちゃんが弟さんの肩に手をす
そうすると弟さんが恐る恐るえはまちゃん
のえ方にあの背中に手をつけてこれ大好き
なシーンで実はあの私の虎さんと浜ちゃん
のえま本会です本をこのえ映画監督に送っ
た映画監督の殺しが自分もとても好きでえ
気に入ってるっていうことおっしゃって
くださったんですけどもあの距離感が
距離感があると苦戦してる時でも人と
つがることが少しりますねはいということ
でえ浜ちゃんは客人に対して1つのま日勝
生活でまとさんがよそ者だったら浜ちゃん
は若者って言ったら失礼
力ま楽天的点的え前向きですねえ相手と
友達なの皆さん今日若い方多いですけど
自分より若い方と知らない人た口て言われ
たら何度生きだと思わるかもしれません
けど相手が自分を友達と思ってくれ
るってことはすごく素敵なことですよね
あの相手の物の言い方の注意は後でやれば
いいですそれからえはまちゃんは相手と
遊ぶということがとてもえ上手ですよね
とにかくたくさんそう皆さん飲み会とか
今日俺わたとえ渾身会パーティがあるよう
ですみんなとあのなんかお茶飲みながら
ご飯食べながら一緒にすですよ楽しいじゃ
ないですかあの食べながら説教するのやめ
ましょうもしですお子さんや先生の立場の
方がいらっしゃったらやめてくださいね
あの食べる時は食べる楽しく食べる楽しく
遊ぶで3つ目はもうあちゃん相手に自分が
み方を見せるこれだけで周りを元気にして
い
ます次が相棒というですねドラマなんです
大好きでえ警視庁のですねやっぱ窓際はの
部署にですね匿名係りっていうのがいて
そこに杉下幸夫さんというえ東大法学の
キャリアなんですけども組織にえ好きな
こといるので窓際に飛ばされたという中で
えこの初代の相棒がえカさんですこれは
あのえ右京さんが知的な立場え河さんがえ
野生的な立場というま分かりやすいペア
ですえ2代目がですねえこれ2人とも知的
な立場ですが向こうの方はええ武さんです
けどもあのお互いにえ知的なんですけどま
え京さんのトラディショナルでえ神部さん
のが少しこうなんて言うのかなえおしゃれ
というかそんな感じですねそれからこれが
今のお相手でえカ徹さんということでこれ
親子のようにえ世代は違うけれども一緒に
やれるよね今の時代え世代交代と言います
けど私が属してる学会は世代交代させて
くれるようの先輩ばかりではありませんの
でえ世代共存と言ってますはいお互いが
共存するはいえ私もだんだん見送られる
世代になっていきますけど世代共存です
からね若い方よく覚えていてください右京
さんは100人に対して多様な繋がりが
できるんです経さんが力を空きするのは
ですね相手が人生の機にる計算ですからね
犯罪の被害者になる加害者として疑われる
人生のきですねとんでもない場面関わっ
てるです私の父は警察官でしたけども本当
に色々な方と関わりがあったように思い
ますでその中で自分の正意感を貫いて
るってことで若者です右京さんの生き方は
相手と相棒になります右さんは相手に対し
て敬語をよく使いますね年下の方でも知日
の女の子でもそれからえ相棒と一緒に前の
人と一緒に問題解決をする謎とにですね
難しいですねね現在これだけ複雑な社会で
しかもグローバルで情報やいろんなものの
流通が激しい中で問題解決して極めて
こんなですだから最近若者や社会人に
求める能力で問題解決って言葉が急にあの
クローズアップされそれだけ難しいから
です皆さん簡単に解けるからじゃない問題
解決は難しいですそれを一緒にしましょう
ということですその時の武さんはパワフル
ですで武さんは正義を守るて人生の覚悟
正義感が強いですねだから私たちは正義で
あれ平和であれ成功であれ自分のこう人生
の核コアの部分を持てるといいですねこの
3人の
えところを少し整理していたますますと
理解するていうところで言うとえ虎さんは
カウンセラーのように共感するあちゃんは
友達よに適度の距離難しいですね適度の
距離感え色々な課題を書いてしている人
ほどカウンセラーとして近づくとうぜえて
言われますよねえあんたみたいな人とは
話したくないて言われますよねでだんだん
距離が適度になっていくとまああんたらは
許してやめようとこ近づけていただけると
ことになりますでえ仏教さんの場合は
とにかくね知識が幅広いですね相手のあの
趣味に合わせてチューニングでき
るっていうのは魅力的ですね私なんか趣味
が限られてますから相手の趣味をした後
あとインターネットとか色々調べてえ
なんかついてるようです次味方になる相手
の世話をする一緒に遊ぶ一緒に問題帰る
こういうやり方あり
ます自分を示すそれさんは自分の失敗だ思
ますえはちゃんは自分が楽しんでることを
見せるどうもですね自分の楽しんでること
を見せるのが我々後輩や子供やえ若い人に
対して少し出ししにしてるような気がする
ですね大人になるのが嫌だなとか海外に
行くのが嫌だなっていう若者が増えてい
ます今あの留学希望者も非常に減ってるん
ですね私はあの32の時にえアメリカに
行って別にエドだから行ったわけじゃなく
て日本でなかなか食えなくていったんです
けどもまあ40ぐらいまでえ働く中で
あるいは勉強する中でなんとかえ武者修を
して日本に帰ってきたわけですけどでも
本当に楽しいこともありました大変なこと
もありましたそれをあの色々な方に伝えて
いきたいなと思っています価値観を示すて
いうのがえ京さんですねまこうしてみると
ですねえ虎さんは私たちの心の中に入って
きて温めて去ってく風のような存在です浜
ちゃんは今のままでいいんだよっていう
私たちに声をかけてくれる呼吸を楽にして
くれる空気のような存在ですひょっとし
たら右京さんは我々の夜空を照らして
くれる星というか僕として
そんなところかなと思います最後にですね
え今日のえお話は人とつながるオリはいつ
か曲をつつけるのが得意な方がいたしたら
是非来ていただいてえいい曲を出してえ
このえテットから世界で発信したいと思い
ますけどもなぜ繋がるのか最後のなぜです
ね危機を共有するんですえ東北の子供たち
は今もプールに入るも夏でもしんどいなん
ていうことがあります苦戦してます責任の
教です我々は参加者として色んなとこに
入ってきますから何らかの形で責によし
希望の共有です私たちは地球市民として
これだけ長い地球の歴史がある素晴らしい
文化があって多様な人たちがいますから力
を合わせれば次の世界は必ず来ます希望を
表示したいと思います私はあのテとつばの
えキャッチフレーズFromToフレと
いう言葉好きなんですね最後にちょっと
被告市場っぽく英語の話しこのスプラ
フレストですけどもあのとても好きなのは
こちっちゃな目が少しずつ広がっていく人
と人とのちっちゃな繋がりが重なって森に
なって地球全体になる国と国との関係は
なかなか大変なところもありますけど
小さいところの繋がりを増やしながらえお
互いに住い日々でお互いにいい人生でお
互いに社会に希望を持って進みたいと思い
ます一歩一歩進むこと一歩一歩の私たちの
全身を祝いながら進みたいと思います今日
はありがとうございまし
た